so as soon as you get good at something
whether it's doing taxes editing videos
running Facebook ads designing websites
you have some craft that you are good at
if you are good your business will grow
and at some point you will be able to
take on more customers you'll have two
options at that point one is that you
can continue to raise the price in that
instance you become the artist you're
continuing to get better and better at
it you still have more and more demand
because you love doing the thing if your
art is business the business of making
that thing and delivering it to lots of
people becomes your art form and that's
when you start hiring and systematizing
the people to deliver that thing on your
behalf most people think that one is
right and one is wrong and I don't think
that's true it's the one that's right
for you if you love doing taxes because
some people do then you should just
continue to raise your taxes and be the
best tax guy in the world and guess what
those guys make a ton of money on the
flip side if you love building the
machine that does taxes then start H R
Block and create the system the business
of taxes and open 500 locations both of
them are passed that can make you a lot
of money but I think the biggest mistake
people make is not knowing which type of
person they are